President Trump goes to the FBI training
headquarters in Quantico Virginia this
morning his speech to law enforcement
managers comes at a sensitive time last
week the president said the bureau's
reputation is quote in tatters over its
handling of recent investigations
Julianna Goldman is at the White House
Juliana good morning good morning well
for most presidents a speech to the FBI
would be par for the course but this is
actually president Trump's first visit
to the FBI his last scheduled appearance
was canceled after he fired former FBI
director James Comey who was very
popular at the bureau and he later
called Comey a liar and a leaker the
circumstances today perhaps just as
fraught coming against the backdrop of
the special counsels ongoing Russia
investigation which has reached top
White House aides and most recently
remember President Trump said the FBI's
reputation is the worst in history that
was after the DOJ Inspector General
found text messages disparaging
then-candidate Trump from a senior FBI
agent who had been working on the Russia
investigation now commis replacement
chris ray had to defend the bureau to
Congress earlier this month saying there
is no finer institution so bianna we
will have to see whether President Trump
echoes those sentiments later today
during his speech it's reminiscent of
his first visit to the CIA Julianna
thank you